story sloths - story sleuth
what is that you've seen bits of my book
yes
stories lot - story sleuth is about so
one of the ways we access the memory
well is through senses and being aware
of the world when you're in it and very
often I find for myself I my thing that
has been taught me through the world is
to disconnect from the world lie on the
couch watch TV read a book even reading
a book is an escape I love it but I must
admit it's an escape because you know
the world is a place where there can be
many things that we feel can injure us
and when we grow up often as a kid you
know things just happen and you're like
oh I need to protect myself I'm gonna
just like very often watch TV screens
which is by the way more and more
happening now I went out to Turner the
other day and they were just kids all
the kids had screens the place even had
screens for the kids I was like wow and
so we can numb ourselves and turn into a
bit of a Slough you know even lie on the
couch and just be a sloth so for me a
story sloth is somebody who just sits at
home on the couch and just like numbs
art and then when they're writing
they're writing from a sort of a numbed
out position almost but the story sleuth
is someone who's looking at the world
being open to the world investigating
the world constantly finding stories
every because they are everywhere and to
do that we have to be open to the world
slightly in some ways we have to have
our magnifying glass and look at the
world and be open to it and allow our
senses to operate and be present this is
again it links up to meditation but
being present in the moment of the world
and folding around us in order to be
open to those stories that are out there
it can be traumatized for me it can be
I'm like I mean I'll see somebody
walking across the road carrying a like
a flip file and they're going somewhere
and then hiring they dress smartly in
laughs that guy's going to a job
interview
he looks so traumatized now if he gets
his job interview like you know I can
relate so much to the world it can
sometimes be a bit overwhelming but I do
think that that further is a
for a riot is is to be a story student
to Gotha and find the stories because
they are everywhere I mean they they can
be overwhelming as to how many stories
they are actually so if you ever stuck
and often my book you know this the
byline has never be stuck again because
it's about breaking through writer's
block breaking through that that limit
that we can feel if we walk around their
stories lose there are just stories
everywhere and I mean it can maybe that
can be overwhelming but also you could
just write the story of the guy going to
his job interview and that'll open up
something so yeah for me this the the
movement from story stuff the story
sleuth is moving from the couch into the
world and there's a great quote which is
something like how vain it is to sit
down and write when you haven't stood up
to live and I like that Wow we need to
stand up to live voice of doubt you're
right that's right you know so that's
the story story smooth going out there
looking for stories and living in the
world and being present and being open
you know not too much because I can also
drive you insane
but yeah yeah have you experienced
writer's block yes I think I have
experienced writer's block probably
quite a lot I have a trick that I do a
few tricks that I do to avoid writer's
block but one name is if I'm writing
something I and I know that there's a
really exciting scene that I'm gonna
write them like heading up to that scene
then I'll just start writing the scene
and I'll stop I wouldn't finish writing
it so that the next day when I have to
sit down to write I'm very excited about
finishing that scene when I experience
writer's block I almost feel like I've
written everything out that I've got in
me already in that one session of
running and then I might put and then
the next morning I wake up and I'm like
oh oh way to now so the excitement of
writing helps it helps me to stop
writing and seem in the middle of the
scene that I really want to write and
then keep that excitement for the next
day but that means already that I'm in a
writing space where I'm writing every
day but to get into the place where
you're writing every day can be even
more difficult I think and that's where
the blocks that's a bigger block I think
when people talk about writer's block I
think they're often talking about
sitting in front of the computer stuck
for me it's real writer's block is I'm
not even sitting in front
you know I'm not even near a computer
I'm like I'm somewhere else I'm like I
don't know on the couch or I'm not even
you know I'm eating breakfast or I'm not
even at the computer yet that's where
the real blocks happened because I'm not
feeling that I have enough to say once
I'm sitting at the computer then another
kind of a block can happen but that's
easily overcome by just writing anything
professional writers do that you know
they just write every day they just
force themselves through the writing and
even before they writing they know it's
terrible it's fine I'll come back and
I'll fix it later in the edits and then
that's a that's maybe a different kind
of writer's block but yeah I've
experienced both kinds the sort of not
even be able to sit in front of the
computer writer's block and then sitting
in front of the computer feeling feeling
blocked it's a it's a strange space but
for me it does help to be able to tap
into these wells like a carry away
what's my memory on this actually do you
have an interesting memory around this
huh and then writing it or okay wait a
minute let me just be imaginative let me
just be playful
let me just imagine something totally
random it's probably terrible but I'm
gonna write it anyway or one of the
movies of our scene there was a scene I
was cool I can write that so for me
tapping into the walls breaks through
the writer's block very very easily and
very effectively yeah and there aren't
there many schools of thought on on
writer's block even somewhere there you
say there is no such thing as writer's
block yeah I think this is why when you
ask me have I ever experience writer's
block I'm like mmm
define writer's I don't really know when
people talk about writer's block and I
don't mention it in my book I just say
never be stuck again and I talk about
the whales and how they can help us be
creative because I don't really know how
to define writer's block I think there
may be many different kinds like as I'm
talking about it now I'm actually
enhancing here there's different kinds
of writers book these like resistance to
writing in general then there's sitting
in front of the computer and feeling
like what you're writing is terrible and
therefore not being able to write so
maybe that's two different kinds and
then I don't know maybe there's another
kind
I can think of two right now and a lot
of professional writers will say no
there's no such thing as writers book
you just sit down and write and there is
there is that you just sit down and just
type the words but what it feels like is
it feels like I'm writing something
that's really terrible and this feels
disgusting but what I've learned to do
is just push through that and write the
disgusting stuff and then fix it later
yeah
you